the LGBTQ community has latched on to
you and your music so much why does it
work so well
and what do you think they do you mean
like what do you what do you think that
you're I don't say that
you know you've found your audience but
this there's not a certain audience of
people that have found you and latched
on to your music and what do you think
that is I get this question a lot and my
answer is always growing up the gays are
always my friends and in in high school
the first guys that I dated okay they
didn't know it yet and in college my
best friends were gay boys you know and
when I when I went out to clubs it was
gay like it's just my community and so
it just makes sense that you know that
as a person and as an artist the things
that I put out draw that community and
and and I'm very comfortable there and
I'm very grateful for what the community
has given me as an artisan and as a
person like you know in high school I
would get made fun of by by most boys
most straight boys and the and the gays
were always there to tell me that I was
I look great and that I was funny and
that I was smart and you know so yeah
it's just kind of organic and natural
and that's where I fit in that's awesome
have you seen the tributes to you like
have you seen any of the drag performers
that do your songs yeah yeah I always
repost drag performances I love I love
drag I think it's such a you have to be
so versatile to do drag and so skills
have so much respect